I thought to myself there's a bigger
story here that connects to really all
the features of a police state because
mean I'm a creature of the 1980s the
Cold War there are police chits of
course now like North Korea China Iran
and of course the old Soviet Union so
then I said well what do those police
states have in common well they have
mass surveillance of citizens they have
systematic censorship they have this
mind-numbing indoctrination and
propaganda in the schools and in the
media they tend to be onep party states
which is to say not that have no
elections but the elections are sort of
controlled so that the if there is an
opposition it's subordinate to the
regime um they criminalize dissent they
go after religious liberty they have
political prisoners and I go whoa all
these elements to one degree or another
I see here in
America are you intentionally trying to
bring that to my first question about
Israel and Hamas because that's what you
basically explained right there we have
one side that's saying we have some
rules and you might not like the rules
that they're playing by but they're
saying we have some rules that have been
borne out of Western ideology and we
have another side saying we're going to
try to kill as many of you and as many
of us as possible actually at the same
time that that's a real problem I mean
with the Hamas thing is so creepy
because the reeling in the massacre of
women and civilians you know there's
been a Trope in America for 30 years
about sort of I think the philosopher
Leo called it the reductio ad hitlerum
everything is linked to the Nazis right
and normally the problem with that is
that the Nazis are so much worse that
the analogy to Nazism always seems like
a little stretch but think about it the
Nazis were very careful to have their
death camps not the concentration camps
which were labor camps but the death
camps outside of Germany they were in
the occupied territories they were in
Poland and that's because the Nazis had
to hide those crimes because they
couldn't say we're gassing the Jews and
we're proud of it they couldn't do that
but the Hamas does that Hamas basically
goes we're killing kids and look here we
are and there's a certain kind of
triumphalism about that that I think is
so morally unnerving that when I see
people defending it or defending the
cause that motivates it it's very
discombobulating so when you see the
sort of chaos that we're seeing right
now these these rallies the protests you
know we're only two three years out of
coid Summer of Love and all of the chaos
related to that um we need law
enforcement to do some things and yet
you're making a movie about the ever
encroaching movement or ever encroaching
growth I suppose of the security State
well I mean we need law enforcement to
do the things that it was empowered to
do I mean this is a little bit like
sometimes when I talk police state I'll
have these Republicans this is like a
classic Republican Congressman response
well dises we're supposed to be back the
blue now you're you're saying the police
state and I'm like like of course I you
know there's no contradiction between
backing the blue and backing the cops
doing what cops are supposed to do and
similarly insisting that the FBI go
after the mafia and go after organized
crime and do the things that the FBI was
set up to do but you know I have to
explain in this movie what is going to
cause an FBI agent by and large a good
guy and in fact sometimes a right of
Center guy to kick into an apartment at
6:00 in the morning go find some
70-year-old grandmother like wrestler to
the ground you know put twist her arms
behind her back and put handcuffs pull
her down the the stairs if she won't go
willingly pull her into the street where
her neighbors come and the gawk at her I
mean how do you get a good guy to do a
bad thing I think that is key to
understanding the psychology of a police
state and that's what people used to ask
about the Nazis actually not to do that
reduct them but I mean that was the same
question these weren't all bad people
five years before yeah and I I
specifically mention um you know Hannah
arent and Her idea about ikan from the
book ikan in Jerusalem that ikan was
yeah he was a Nazi but that wasn't what
motivated him he was sort of like I want
to be part of a really efficient system
I'm like a I'm an upand andc Comer I
want to I want to be recognized for my
own creative efforts and so I'll Ally
with this cause and I'll become a sort
of master builder of this cause and so
this was Ren's famous race the banality
of evil because this guy was not all
about uh you know let's let's R rid
Europe of the Jews he was ultimately an
opportunist and a social climber and I
think that is an important Insight you
need they're evil people and then you
have evil people who set up bureaucratic
mechanisms to get good people and and
and just ordinary people who want to get
ahead in life to to do those bad things
was the Genesis of this movie January
6th or I'm guessing you've been you've
obviously been kicking these ideas
around for quite some time but was that
really the the thing that got you to
make it I started out thinking the
reaction let's say to January well I
started out thinking that there is an
untold story about January 6th and I
think we actually have it in the movie
by that I mean I always like to not just
recycle what other people are saying but
break new ground in understanding an
event and we can talk about that if you
like but but I started out saying I've
got an insight about January 6 let's do
a movie on that then I realized there
are four or five other guys making a
January 6 movie and so I pulled back and
I thought to myself there's a bigger
story here that connects to really all
the features of a police station because
me I'm a creature of the 1980s the Cold
War there are police hits of course now
like North Korea China Iran and of
course the old Soviet Union so then I
said well what do those police states
have in common well they have mass
surveillance of citizens they have
systematic censorship they have this
mind-numbing indoctrination and
propaganda in the schools and in the
media they tend to be one party states
which is to say not that they have no
elections but the elections are sort of
controlled so that the if there is an
opposition it's subordinate to the
regime um they criminalize disent they
go after religious liberty they have
political prisoners and I go whoa all
these elements to one degree or another
I see here in America and it's a shock
for me because I'm an immigrant I mean
you know I've written books like what's
so great about America uh been very much
of a an American exceptionalist a Rah
American
triumphalist and yet that America is not
the America we're living in now so this
movie to that degree has a personal
dimension it's like what happened to
those Liberties and the Bill of Rights
that were supposed to be
unalienable above political negotiation
not subject to majoritarian
overthrow uh suddenly all those rights
are in Jeopardy do you think our
institutions have enough of a sort of
self-correcting system within them to
fix some of this I mean it seems to me
right now if we didn't have a supreme
court that leans the way it does we
would be seriously seriously screwed and
as we're taping this right now the
Republicans can't even figure out at a
speaker of the house like it could end
up being a Democrat that's how that's
how insane with a republican majority
could end up a Democrat house you know
in essence controlled house it is it is
absolutely uh absolutely nuts now look
we're not a full-fledged police state
obviously if we were we wouldn't be
having this conversation and I wouldn't
be making this movie so when the jaws of
the police stage snapshot I have Yan
Park who's a North Korean Refugee she's
a friend and you know Yan me goes listen
when when the jaws of the police state
are shut there's no time that remains
all you can do is run yeah you know get
out get your family out get your money
out but but we're not there um now I
think the reason our institutions have
proven so vulnerable is is one because
there have been these sort of fear
inducing events let's start with 911 but
then let's add co uh let's even add
January 6th because if you think about
it all of those were pretexts for
massive expansions of state power and
encroachments on Liberty that would not
otherwise have occurred you can't tell
Americans you can't go to a church you
can't go to synagogue unless you got
it's a virus or you can't do it for that
reason and similarly I think the idea
that you can't talk about eight subjects
on social media it was after January 6th
that that became okay to say and and
YouTube is like proudly listing all the
things you can't talk about um so you
could deny elections let's say for four
years before that under Trump the second
it went the other way then it was it was
it was restricted exactly uh the other
thing I want to say that I think a lot
of Americans are fooled because our
police state doesn't come in the usual
kind of cartoon Colors by that I mean
Americans think well if it's a where's
the Revolutionary overthrow of the
government that say lennin did where's
the Stalin Overcoat where's the Hitler
mustache our police state is very
cunning and it marches behind the banner
of law saving democracy upholding Truth
by by prohibiting misinformation and
even affirming Liberty so it's a
disguised police state um and it uses a
lot of camouflage if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
screaming check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell